welcome to sales talks money on
valuetainment i'm your host adam sosnick
and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode we're
gonna be breaking down the world's
wealthiest billionaires let's talk money
all we
so question for you during the pandemic
do you think
billionaire wealth has gone up or down
what do you think because if you
answered up you would be
absolutely right don't believe me check
out this clip i recently filmed on the
business
news for busy people billionaires have
never
been richer despite the pandemic
billionaire wealth increased to 10.2
trillion dollars over the summer
up from a previous peak of 8.9 trillion
in 2017 so the major reason for this
is the stock market so what i did is i
said you know what all these
billionaires are getting wealthier
let me dig a little bit deeper on this
topic
and here's what i uncovered according to
cnbc
when you're talking billionaires in the
world there are 2
825 billionaires walking around
planet earth today now how many are in
america good question
well there's 614 billionaires here in
the united states let me break that down
for a little bit further
22 of billionaires in the world are in
the united states
despite the us only having four percent
of the world's population
all right cool so billionaires high
concentration united states
let's talk about millionaires you want
to talk about millionaires well here you
go
in the world today there are 47
million millionaires 47 million
millionaires in the world and 18.6
million of them
are here in the united states that is
actually 40
of the world's millionaires now being a
millionaire is pretty cool don't get me
wrong but
now it's all about being a billionaire i
remember back in like 2010 there was a
song that came out from
travie mccoy and bruno mars and it was i
want to be a billionaire
so freaking bad i was like damn it's not
even cool to be a millionaire anymore
it's all about being a billionaire very
interesting
let's talk about countries with the most
billionaires obviously number one is the
united states 614
billionaires as we discussed let's go
down the list here rapid fire style
number two is china with 388 number
three
germany 107 number four india 102
billionaires
number five russia 99 hong kong's got 67
brazil's got 45 the united kingdom's got
canada 44 and number 10 on the list is
france
with 39 now let's talk about
millionaires let's talk about
millionaires how many millionaires
are around the world top 10 countries
with the most millionaires obviously we
said that number one
is the united states 18.6 million china
number
two at 4.4 million millionaires number
three is japan
three million number four is the uk 2.5
million
five germany 2.2 million number six is
france 2.1 million
number seven australia 1.2 million then
you got spain at 980
000 so not even millions at that point
980 000.
number nine is india at 760 000
millionaires and last but not least you
got brazil
260 000 millionaires so that's your
breakdown of how many
billionaires and millionaires are across
the globe that's your top ten
now we said the top ten now let's get
into the top 20
wealthiest billionaires on planet earth
today
now who's number one i'm sure you've
heard this man's name before i'm sure
you're buying tons of stuff
from this person's company number one
person on the list
is jeff bezos he's worth 197
billion dollars just a little bit shy of
200 billion don't feel bad for that guy
i'm sure he'll get there
he's 56 years old and he is out of the
united states
out of miami florida if you didn't know
that his company is amazon i'm sure you
knew that in his sector and industry
is technology who's number two number
two is
bill gates he's worth 117 billion he's
out of the united states
he is the founder of microsoft that is
another
tech company so the top two are tech
companies on this list number three we
got our first
non-american on the list his name is
bernard arno did i say that okay he is
french
he's 71 years old and he's worth 116
billion dollars his company is lvmh that
stands for
louis vuitton moet hennessy how's my
french accent
he's in the fashion and retail industry
okay so
top two tech now we got fashion number
three number four we got zuck
mark zuckerberg we're all on facebook we
know the deal he's worth just
shy of a hundred billion dollars 99.9
billion dollars he's 36 years old he is
the youngest
person on this list he founded facebook
that is another technology company
moving right along we got number five he
is the rising rocket on this list we got
elon
musk he is now worth 96 billion dollars
he's just shy of 50 at 49 years old
he hails from south africa but now he
claims the united states he's a resident
of the us
he founded tesla and spacex his industry
is tech
space and obviously auto so elon musk's
wealth was
a fraction of this before the pandemic
his wealth has skyrocketed
no pun intended on the spacex number six
you have
our first asian person on this list this
is mukesh
ambani he's worth 88 billion dollars
he's 63 years old
and he is out of india respect to my
indian friends out there he started
reliance
energy they are in the energy oil and
gas
business so that is our first energy
sector on our top 20 list
number seven we got larry ellison he's
the founder of
oracle oracle's in the software and tech
space
he's worth 80 billion dollars he's 76
years old
and you might have heard his name in the
news recently because oracle just
put together a little deal to take over
a partnership with tick tock
i know that's very confusing and the
news keeps changing every single day
but look out for the name larry ellison
oracle with tick tock
there you go number eight we got warren
buffett we all know the name the
greatest investor of all time the oracle
of omaha is the oldest person on this
list at 90 years old
he's worth 79 billion and depending on
how the market fluctuates
day to day he might move up or down this
list
his company is called berkshire hathaway
and he is the first person in finance
and investments on the top 20 list
number nine you got steve ballmer he's
worth 74 billion dollars he was the ceo
for microsoft for like 15 years he was
the number two guy
under bill gates he was actually the
number 30
higher within microsoft so here's
something to know about steve ballmer
he's not an entrepreneur
he's not the founder of the company he's
an intrapreneur
who made his billions running alongside
mr bill gates
they're obviously in the technology
sector with microsoft
moving right along you got number 10 and
number 11 these are the two
founders of google this is larry page
and sir
j brin they're worth 70 billion and 68
billion
combined that's 138 billion they're both
47 years old
united states google technology sector
if you don't know who these guys are go
ahead and google them you see that
then number 12 you got francois
bettencourt myers
that's the second french person i love
using the french accent when i'm talking
about these people she's worth
67 billion she hails from france and her
family founded
l'oreal right so that's in the fashion
retail
makeup industry there we go number 13
you know what number 13 is actually an
interesting one because they could have
taken up
the second half of this list it is the
walton family
walton family their father sam walton's
founded
walmart that's the biggest shopping and
retail
company in america and you got rob alice
and jim
the three the two brothers and sister
they're worth collectively
67 billion a piece you add that up
that's 200 billion if they did the whole
family
they'd be number one on this entire list
they're obviously
out of the united states number fourteen
you got amancio ortega
amigo de espana he's worth 66 billion
dollars he's 84 years old
he's from the fashion industry and he
founded zara if you're looking to save
that money and find some good clothing
go check out zara that's a free plug for
zara right there number 14 we have our
first
chinese person on this list we got pony
ma huatwang did i say that name right
pony
ma tang he's worth 61 billion dollars
he's from china 49
years old he's the founder and ceo of
tencent they own wechat so if you
haven't heard of these companies
check them out they're in the technology
space in china
moving right along you got mike
bloomberg the mayor of new york city
he's worth 55 billion
he's 78 years old he founded bloomberg
lp
there in the finance and media space he
had a brief stint trying to run
for the president of the united states
he was in and out in like less than a
month
but he spent over a hundred million
dollars so that's mike bloomberg
number 17 we have our first mexican on
the list we got carlos
slim helu carlos slim halo he's worth 53
billion dollars he's 80 years old and
he's out of mexico obviously his company
is a
america mobile they're in the telecom
space
that's the number one telecommunications
provider in mexico
number 18 you got our second chinese
person on this list you got jack
ma he's actually a pretty famous person
uh he's worth 52 billion dollars he's 56
years old
he's obviously chinese he started ali
baba which is in the e-commerce space
in china number 19 rounding out this
list you got phil knight he's the
founder of
nike he's worth 48 billion dollars he's
82 years old he actually stepped down
not too long ago obviously nike in the
fashion retail
and shoe sector number 20 the last
person on this list they're kind of like
the waltons
but they're not public they're not a
public company they're actually the
second largest
private company in america you got the
coke family you got charles
and his late brother david's wife who
now has the
money in the family julia they're worth
billion dollars a piece you add that up
that's 90 billion
he's 85 years old she's 58 they're
obviously out of the united states now
what kind of business
they're in it's pretty diversified
they're private companies we don't know
everything about them but what we do
know is they're in the pipeline business
and the chemical business so that's the
koch family and last but not least
they're not in the top 20
but this just talks about how powerful
number one is
number 21 on this list is actually the
ex-wife
of jeff bezos her name is mackenzie
scott she's worth
40 billion dollars because she owns
four percent of amazon interesting she's
out of the united states as well
she's in the tech space she's an author
now and quite frankly she can do
whatever the hell she wants to do now
that she's single
she's only 50 years old and she's worth
billion freaking dollars so that's the
top 20
billionaires in the world right there
with a little throw in at number 21
from jeff bezos's ex-wife you're just
throwing an extra 40 billion for us
no biggie right there all right so
what's my biggest takeaways well number
one it's pretty obvious if you look all
up and down this list you see nothing
but blue it's all about usa usa usa
capitalism works let me recap those
numbers for you
we have 22 percent of the world's
billionaires we have 40 percent of the
world's
millionaires and 13 people in the top 20
all hail from united states don't be
talking trash about capitalism
because it works number two second
biggest takeaway here is there's
definitely
many different ways to make money
different sectors
and different lines of business so we
got technology obviously that's number
one we got fashion and retail
energy we got telecom we got e-commerce
there's different ways to make money
it's not all just in one sector
second part of that is you don't
necessarily have to be an entrepreneur
like elon musk or bill gates you can
also be an
intrapreneur like steve ballmer our ceo
patrick bet david
talks about it in his book your next
five moves if you're not an entrepreneur
that's okay you could be an
entrepreneur and be a number two guy
company number three guy in the company
like steve ballmer was with microsoft
and he's now worth
74 billion dollars he was the number two
at microsoft he's also the number two
team in la he's the owner of the los
angeles clippers los angeles lakers just
won a world championship
we'll see what the clippers end up doing
but that's steve ballmer for you
my number three biggest takeaway is you
need to follow
your passion i doubt anyone on this list
behind me was like i really really
really want to be a billionaire
no it's something that happened
accidentally
and that was the outcome of the passion
that they put in
to their business they stuck with it
they took on risk
and they stayed the course no matter the
ups and the downs that their business
face
so follow your passion my number four
biggest takeaway is you need to tune out
the haters
you think the people on this list don't
have haters these are some of the most
hated people on the planet they say if
you don't got haters you're not doing
something right
so they're dealing with the heat they're
dealing with the haters but they stay
with the game plan that's my number four
biggest takeaway
and number five my final takeaway from
this entire list as these guys started
to make
buku bucks and what did they do with
that money
well they saved that money they didn't
spend it
and they reinvested it into their
business
that's how they grew their business more
and more
and more and more so that's my biggest
takeaways from this top
20 billionaire list so that's it i hope
you enjoyed this episode
and i hope that inspired you in some way
to follow your
dreams with that being said i want you
to check out a couple of these clips
number one
ten things that are killing your wealth
and number two
how to have a game plan for your money
if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment economics please do so
below and give that like button a smash
while you're at it and as always save
that money all we talk is